le monde de bob l'épongé pour toi gary
est remplie dany a laissé tout le monde
avec moi douceur et le temps gris
j'ai joué avec lui ma venue à la
projection de bienvenue à
l'avant-première on en vit depuis à
chaque fois jusqu'à 10h mais qui faut-il
appeler les pouces carrés tu n'as pas
peur des coups du sommet
sumô n'y fut comme les banques le fait
des projections amusez vous bien c'est
sympa ça ni mais c'est rigolo c'est
coloré c'est vivant qui fort il est
drôle et ça rappelle plein de souvenirs
en fait je pense qu'ils n'en font pas ça
très bons moments et les adultes aussi
on retombe en enfance en fait ils vont
tous des super héros se nomme patrick ou
plus gros et plus d'actions sam est de
très bonne humeur
je craque selmyar fou que j'ai vu ma vie
bob l'eponge le film un héros sort de
l'eau à très vite au cinéma